merci Vincent delay de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes sénateur centriste de l'Essonne
vice-président du Sénat on a beaucoup de
sujets d'actualité à voir avec vous on
commence par un mot ce qui s'est passé
ce week-end en Russie et cette rébellion
avortée de prigognes chef de Wagner
est-ce que quand même Vladimir Poutine
sera faibli tout ça pour vous forcément
il sera affaibli et je pense que même
depuis le début de la guerre en Ukraine
l'Armée rouge sort affaibli aussi on
faisait de la Russie un épouvantail
l'Armée rouge ils ont du mal ils ont du
mal déjà à sortir du crâne et ils ont
une rébellion chez eux qui arrivent à
400 km de Moscou et sur laquelle le
président Poutine qui était soi-disant
tout puissant est obligé de négocier
pour qu'il se passe rien on a
l'impression quand même qu'il y a une
des faiblesses intérieures très forte au
niveau de la Russie
l'autre
sens du Journal du dimanche dans les
kiosques les salariés ont grève pour
protester contre la nomination de
Geoffroy Lejeune qui vient de valeurs
actuelles à la tête de leur rédaction la
ministre de la Culture dit comprendre
les inquiétudes de la rédaction et pose
cette question je cite pour nos valeurs
républicaines comment ne pas s'alarmer
que pensez-vous de ce tweet de la
ministre
je pense qu'il faut des actionnaires
dans les pour faire tourner des médias
et des journaux donc il y a besoin il y
a besoin d'argent il y a besoin d'accès
après c'est à l'actionnaire bien sûr de
s'entendre avec ses salariés avec sa
rédaction en l'occurrence pour les
médias et que les salariés fassent part
de leur de mécontentement de leurs
inquiétudes ça me paraît légitime ça me
paraît légitime après voilà
c'est ce que propose par exemple Olivier
fort le premier
directeur de la rédaction ne soit pas
désigné sans la sentiment de sa
rédaction c'est une bonne idée j'en sais
rien je honnêtement je n'en sais rien je
sais pas parce que il faudra quand même
qu'il y ait des capitaux pour faire
tourner ces médias donc si on a plus de
capitaux après six personnes veut
investir on n'aura plus de média et on
va pas voir que des médias d'État sinon
on vient à l'ORTF c'est donc honnêtement
c'est c'est pas un sujet facile c'est
pas un sujet facile et en même temps je
comprends à la fois l'actionnaire qui a
envie de d'avoir un média qui lui
correspondent et aussi les salariés qui
de notre côté s'inquiète donc c'est pas
si c'est pour ça il va influer sur la
ligne idéologique du Journal du Dimanche
c'est ce qui cherche à faire forcément
forcément forcément ce qu'il a fait dans
d'autres médias donc après c'est pas moi
de juger c'est bien c'est pas bien j'en
sais rien mais qui fait pas que de
l'économie il fait de la politique il
fait tout de la politique
personnellement ça me choque pas moi que
que il y a des citoyens et qui est
beaucoup pas beaucoup d'argent qui ait
envie de s'intéresser à la chose
publique moi je dirais que tout le monde
devrait s'intéresser à chose publique
donc
on parle d'argent mais sur un une autre
un autre sujet vous êtes membre de la
commission des finances la semaine
dernière le gouvernement a tenu des
Assises des finances publiques
l'objectif c'est de réduire la dépense
publique il a annoncé de première mesure
10 milliards d'économistes à rush qu'à
12 milliards dans le budget 2024 c'est
ce que dit le gouvernement est-ce que
vous suivez cette trajectoire d'abord je
la trouve totalement insuffisante et
puis c'est jamais c'est pas des
économies en fait c'est une moindre
progression de la dépense c'est toujours
pareil on dit on dit on fait des
économies dans l'esprit des gens c'est
qu'on diminue la dépense en réalité
c'est pas vrai du tout on essaye de
faire en sorte qu'elle n'augmente pas
autant que ce qu'elle augmenterait
naturellement et en même temps
parallèlement on a des annonces quasi
quotidiennes de dire on met un milliard
ici on met un milliard là attendez c'est
pas sérieux ah c'est totalement
contradictoire et moi j'aimerais bien
entendre le président de la République
là il a fait une grande interview vous
l'avez parlé dans La Provence est-ce
qu'il a parlé de la situation financière
de la France la situation budgétaire
j'ai pas l'impression du tout que le
Président de la République qui est en
fait le premier ministre parce que
aujourd'hui la façon dont le président
de la République agit puis depuis le
quinquennat de toute façon le Président
c'est quasiment le Premier ministre on
se demande à quoi sert le Premier
ministre puisque c'est lui qui détermine
y compris les paiements des amendes pour
sur adrogue donc à partir de là moi je
l'ai pas entendu du tout se saisir de ce
sujet là qui est pour moi par exemple à
Marseille il a mis 5 milliards qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire il fallait pas les
mettre là il faut pas en remettre il
faut pas lancer un on peut continuer on
peut continuer à vivre à crédit comme ça
longtemps c'est à dire que c'est les
nouvelles génération ça veut dire que
c'est votre génération c'est c'est les
autres générations qui paieront toutes
nos dettes moi je considère que chaque
génération doit s'assumer donc
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas du tout
donc effectivement on peut continuer à
emprunter alors avant on disait que
l'argent était gratuit il n'est plus
gratuit aujourd'hui ça coûte très très
cher 55 milliards d'intérêt là l'année
prochaine
ça va nous coûter c'est le deuxième
budget de l'État vous rendez compte on
paye 55 milliards au marché financier et
tout le monde personne n'y trouve rien
il faut de vrais économies pas seulement
une baisse de la dépense il faut les
trouver partout partout
il y a pas il y a pas qu'un seul endroit
où il faut le trouver moi j'ai fait des
tas de propositions à la fois sur le
personnel sur sur des tas de dépenses
par exemple les frais de communication
les frais de communication dépense
énormément les frais partout y compris
sur l'éducation y compris dans
l'éducation nationale on n'arrête pas
d'augmenter les moyens depuis des années
et les résultats baissent la sécurité
écoutez il faut il faut partout moi je
vous dis c'est partout puisque vous
allez étudier le budget de l'armée cette
semaine mais partout il y a 55 millions
de budget de communication de l'armée je
pense qu'on peut faire des économies
dessus voilà je pense qu'on peut être
plus efficace dans la dépense publique
on peut avoir moins de dépenses
publiques et de la dépense plus efficace
donc aujourd'hui on dépense de plus en
plus chaque année et en fait les gens
sont de moins en moins contents des
services donc il y a un problème faut
supprimer des fonctionnaires aussi mais
peut-être peut-être que le fait de
remplacer un fonctionnaire sur deux ça
allait très bien moi je supprimerai je
supprimerai pas toutes les études c'est
par les fonctionnaires bon voilà je
considère que on fait trop d'études en
France il y a trop de rapports qui se
terminent dans un tiroir et que c'est
pas une bonne chose
on va parler des autoroutes les vacances
approchent de nombreux Français vont
emprunter ses autoroutes la question du
prix des péages fait toujours des bas
vous avez travaillé évidemment sur cette
question des concessions autoroutières
et le Sénat poursuit ses travaux sur le
sujet on fait le point avec notre
journaliste parlementaire Alex fossa
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Vincent Delage jour
sur la rentabilité excessive des
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute
après avoir été alerté par le Sénat
depuis des années effectivement depuis
2020 une commission d'enquête à l'époque
du Sénat sur le sujet avec déjà alerté
sur une rentabilité hors norme des
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute
ces sociétés privées qui gèrent les
autoroutes depuis leur privatisation en
2006 des conclusions qui ont été
confirmées ces dernières années par
d'autres enquêtes de l'État en 2021
c'est société concessionnaires ont
réalisé par exemple un bénéfice net de
3,9 milliards d'euros une hausse de 11%
par rapport à 2019 et le problème c'est
que ces dernières années et bien les
tarifs des péages augmentent également
plus 2% en 2022 quasiment plus 5% cette
année alors du coup le gouvernement a
décidé de se pencher sur la question de
leur côté les sénateurs ont relancé un
cycle d'audition des représentants du
secteur autoroutier notamment du patron
de Vinci le principal concessionnaire
autoroutier et selon lui et bien ces
bénéfices ne sont pas
il faut surtout se réjouir de la qualité
de ce réseau autoroutier nous sommes
très fiers d'avoir construit un réseau
qui est manifestement considéré comme le
meilleur réseau autoroutier du monde et
il suffit de voyager en Europe pour le
constater lorsqu'on regarde la
satisfaction des clients on a un niveau
de satisfaction qui est entre 8 et 9 sur
10 bon des clients satisfaits alors
justement et bien les sénateurs ont
aussi auditionné les associations
d'usagers de la route alors certes ils
sont contents de la qualité du réseau
mais moins du montant des péages écoutez
les tarifs sont dissuasifs car avec
l'augmentation des prix de péage
d'autoroute beaucoup d'usagers se
trouvent aujourd'hui
contraint ou choisissent pour faire des
économies des économies de cette dépense
de ne plus emprunter les réseaux
autoroutiers l'évolution de la hausse
des prix des péages d'autoroute au nom
de l'investissement dans les
infrastructures de sécurité et les
services se fait donc par axe paradoxe
allemand au détriment de l'accessibilité
du réseau et participe au renforcement
des inégalités sociales et au final le
gouvernement est en train d'étudier la
possibilité d'une taxe sur les
autoroutes quelques centaines de
millions d'euros par an jusqu'en 2030 et
on le rappelle ces concessions
autoroutières vont prendre fin à partir
de 2031 Vincent Delahaye cette taxe
autoroute qui est en train de dessiner
notamment par Bruno Le Maire est-ce
qu'elle est suffisante selon vous
bien sûr que non elle est pas du tout
suffisante nous nous avions réclamé des
grandes assises des autoroutes ce que le
gouvernement a fait sommet des
autoroutes pour l'instant il n'y a rien
alors moi quand j'entends quand
j'entends monsieur Copé nous dire qu'il
a construit des autoroutes ok sur
koffrir route sur la 10 mais tout le
reste c'était déjà construit n'a rien
construit du tout il gère bien ok mais
il gère ça coûte très très cher
effectivement à l'usager on a augmenté
3,75%, vous avez dit 3 milliards 9 tout
à l'heure de résultats annuels ça va ça
va augmenter leur profit de 300 millions
d'euros chaque année ces 3,75%. donc
4,75%. donc à un moment donné il faut
dire stop et moi je souhaite que le
gouvernement dise aujourd'hui qui est le
patron en matière de concession
d'autoroute est-ce que c'est
concessionnaires qui qui décident de
tout ou est-ce que c'est l'État qui a
concédé qui décide aussi et pour moi
c'est l'État qui est le patron
aujourd'hui
c'est c'est pas eux qui doivent faire la
loi et à partir du moment où on
considère que les contrats sont
largement rentables et que la
rentabilité attendue a été atteinte à
partir de ce moment-là moi je considère
qu'on peut dénoncer les contrats je l'ai
dit à partir de la fin d'année Vinci
aura 8 % de rentabilité même s'ils font
0 jusqu'à la fin des contrats et leur
fin de contrats c'est 2036 donc à un
moment donné il faut s'arrêter il faut
arrêter de nous amuser alors avec une
une taxe maintenant nous parle d'une
taxe la baisse de l'impôt sur les
sociétés rapportent jusqu'à la fin des
contrats à peu près 7 milliards aux
sociétés d'autoroute et ce qu'on va leur
réclamer c'est éventuellement 2
milliards attendez c'est pas du tout à
la hauteur de l'enjeu donc il faut
aujourd'hui reprendre tout ce dossier en
main et qu'il faut avoir un peu de
courage de la part du gouvernement faut
pas avoir peur des contentieux à
contentieux ça peut se faire et voilà et
aujourd'hui on ne sent pas cette volonté
on sent pas ce courage c'est ça qui est
tombé top donc un contentieux le fait de
dénoncer les contrats ça ne va pas
coûter au final plus cher à l'État on
verra dans 10 ou 15 ans parce que vous
savez ce genre de contentieux ça dure 10
ou 15 ans moi je pense que ça va obliger
les sociétés à se mettre autour de la
table si vous les invitez aujourd'hui
sur votre plateau vous pensez qu'ils
vont venir non il viendront pas ils
viennent nulle part en fait ils
répondent nulle part ils disent on est
pour la transparence mais en fait ils
veulent jamais en parler donc moi ça me
ça me fait doucement rire quoi ça me
fait même pas rire mais bon en je trouve
pas ça sérieux c'est pas sérieux de
parler transparence de ne jamais être
autour de la table et je pense que le
gouvernement doit les obliger à venir
autour de la table et s'il commençait à
dire on va dénoncer ces contrats et je
suis sûr qu'il serait autour de la table
très rapidement qu'est-ce que vous
répondez au patron de Vinci qui dit et
bien c'est bénéfices ne sont pas un des
super profits et en plus on a les
meilleurs autoroutes du monde donc ils
sont justifiés pour moi c'est super
profit puisque on a atteint on aura
atteint à la fin de l'année là je vous
dis les 8% de rentabilité 8% c'est déjà
pas mal sur un investissement si vous
avez 8 % par an même si vous faites 0
jusqu'à la fin des contrats vous avez
vous les aurez atteint donc à partir de
ce moment-là tout ce qui va partir de là
c'est de la surentabilité et cette
surentabilité cet argent c'est 30
milliards moi j'ai chiffré entre 30 et
35 milliards c'est de l'argent qu'on
peut mettre ailleurs on en a besoin pour
la transition énergétique on en a besoin
pour plein d'autres choses et donc c'est
de l'argent qui doit pour pouvoir être
discuté alors dans ces auditions le
Sénat a également entendu le patron de
la RT l'Autorité de régulation des
transports Philippe Richer et il a
alerté les sénateurs sur un point qui
est assez problématique les sociétés
concessionnaires prévoyaient des hausses
de tarif pour financer des travaux mais
des travaux qui étaient déjà financés
donc Philippe Richard dit on a failli et
bien financer deux fois ces travaux
autoroutiers comment vous l'expliquez il
y a eu une forme de négligence de la
part de l'État dans le contrôle de ses
contrats il y a eu de la négligence
pendant de longues années depuis 2015 on
peut dire que c'est nettement mieux
réaliser ce contrôle heureusement et
heureusement que la RT aussi est
vigilante donc c'est une autorité qui
fait attention et c'est vrai que sur ce
sujet à la fois des travaux du
financement travaux des retards
éventuellement qui prennent parce qu'ils
s'engagent à faire des travaux mais à
chaque fois il est fort avec retard et
donc c'est quand même très embêtant donc
aujourd'hui je dirais que c'est
nettement mieux suivi
ça pourrait peut-être être mieux mais en
tout cas c'est nettement mieux celui que
ça ne n'était ça sur le prix des péages
parce que évidemment ça inquiète les
Français et encore plus à la proche des
vacances Clément bonnes le ministre des
Transports appellent les sociétés
d'autoroute à faire des ristournes sur
le prix de CPH pendant les vacances
d'été alors il semble avoir été un peu
entendu puisque Vinci annonce offrir une
ression de 20% mais sous conditions un
abonnement télépéage aux utilisateurs de
chaque vacance est-ce que vous dites
c'est mieux que rien c'est c'est comme
l'an dernier quoi c'est une mesure est
c'est une mesure est on nous amuse on
amuse la galerie on fait de la
communication combien ça a coûté à Vincy
l'an dernier moi j'aimerais bien savoir
à ma connaissance ça a coûté moins de 20
millions d'euros quand vous organisez
300 millions de plus avec l'augmentation
de 4,75 % vous voyez vous vous en
redonnez 20 millions il faut il faut
faire plus que 20%, il faut pas
conditionner à des chèques-vacances clé
il disait mais ça concerne 5 millions
d'utilisateurs les chèques-vacances
finalement c'est une démarche facile
c'est une bonne chose je suis pas sûr
qu'il fasse tous la démarche d'abord et
moi j'aimerais bien savoir il y a aucune
transparence on va être sur le sujet
donc on parle de quelque chose vous êtes
en train de m'en parler mais en fait on
a aucun chiffre moi j'aime bien avoir
des chiffres moi j'aime bien les
chiffres j'aime bien avoir des chiffres
savoir combien de français sont
concernés combien ça a coûté voilà pour
moi on devrait faire beaucoup plus
d'abord les 4,75% c'était pas justifié
pour moi on devait faire 1,8%. donc à un
moment donné alors bien sûr on va nous
dire c'est le contrat mais à un moment
donné la puissance publique c'est
d'ailleurs l'État le gouvernement doit
pouvoir taper du poids sur la table et
dire stop on arrête on arrête cette ces
contrats qui sont des contrats qui
n'étaient pas adaptés à une gestion par
le privé donc à un moment donné il faut
les vacances d'été vous demander quoi
mais moi je demande une ristourne pour
tout le monde beaucoup plus importante
donc sans condition voilà sans condition
il y a pas il y a pas d'histoire de
condition de savoir si on paye par
chèque vacances ou pas par
chèque-vacances si non l'augmentation
était trop importante on peut avoir
avoir une réduction qui soit générale
l'augmentation a été générale la
réduction elle doit être générale
à tout à l'heure on parlera d'autre
chose
on va voir l'actualité dans votre
département dans votre région on trouve
jackpotier directeur de la rédaction du
journal du Grand Paris bonjour Jacques
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous Jacques
avec vous on s'intéresse financement là
aussi mais financement des transports
publics en Île-de-France absolument et
ça tombe bien on va continuer de parler
de chiffres monsieur le sénateur vous
dites que vous aimez les chiffres alors
donc ce c'est un rapport de l'Inspection
générale des finances et de l'inspection
générale de l'environnement du
développement durable qui défrait la
chronique ce week-end il porte sur
l'évolution du financement de de
l'Île-de-France mobilité qui est
l'autorité organisatrice des transports
en Île-de-France
il dit que ces dépenses vont beaucoup
augmenter en passant de 10 milliards
d'euros en 2022 à 16 milliards d'euros
en 2035 des dépenses qui ne sont pas
couvertes par le modèle de financement
actuel et
Monsieur delay vous avez vu que
parmi les pistes de d'augmentation des
recettes de l'Île-de-France mobilité
figure celles du Pass Navigo qui à
chaque fois crée le débat on parle d'un
Pass Navigo à 120 euros monsieur le
sénateur que pensez-vous de ce rapport
et de ces et ces pistes de des recettes
d'Île-de-France mobilité
écoutez quand il y a un coup il faut
toujours le financer donc et quand c'est
un service public il faut savoir ce que
paye l'usager et ce que va payer le
contribuable parce qu'il y a forcément
quelqu'un qui va payer donc si vous ne
bougez pas le passe Navigo pendant des
années finalement c'est le contribuable
qui paye plus et si vous l'augmentez
payera plus et un peu moins contribuable
donc moi je suis je suis pour un
équilibre bien sûr entre les deux mais
on a on a un retard d'investissement qui
est en train de se combler mais bah
c'est c'est lent mais ça se comble et ça
ça nécessite forcément un financement
donc dire je pense que c'est hyper
démagogique de dire que le Pass Navigo
ne bougera pas je pense qu'il faut
accepter que le Pass Navigo augmente
je dirais tout augmente et en même temps
on a des besoins de financement les
usagers à ton service de qualité si on
veut avoir un service de qualité il faut
investir et si on investit faut
forcément un financement donc voilà moi
je sais pas si c'est 120 euros mais à un
moment donné il va falloir quand même se
se mettre en route pour que il y a des
augmentations régulières et qu'en même
temps effectivement peut-être que le
contribuable aussi contribue d'une façon
ou d'une autre mais on a déjà un très
gros déficit au niveau de l'État vous
savez que ça fait 160 augmentation du
passe Navigo que par des aides
supplémentaires de l'État sans doute
sans doute j'ai pas en tête le
pourcentage de financement de
l'Île-de-France mobilité par le Pass
Navigo c'est-à-dire que les usagers
combien ils financent en pourcentage
de 20% si je dis pas de bêtises 20% du
coup par l'usager ça me semble pas non
plus énorme donc si on passait à 25%, ça
me paraîtrait pas d'émanciennes même
voire 30%
un tiers du coup financé par les usagers
ça me semble pas non plus d'émancienne
monsieur sénateur il y a d'autres pistes
qui sont qui sont évoqués par le rapport
notamment celle de la création d'une
nouvelle taxe sur l'immatriculation des
véhicules de plus de 1,4 tonnes des
véhicules de touristes je pense que
c'est pour lutter contre les les fameux
SUV dont on sait qu'il polluent même
quand ils sont et puis et puis on peut
éventuellement je pense pas que les
rapporteurs soient très favorables mais
augmenter aussi le versement mobilité
que paye les entreprises vous pensez que
ce sont aussi des pistes à explorer
alors le versement mobilité ça déjà
évolué après moi je ne suis pas
favorable à la création de nouvelles
taxes je trouve qu'on a déjà beaucoup et
que c'est comme les niches fiscales ou
comme les normes ou comme les règlements
à chaque fois qu'on en crée une il faut
en supprimer deux donc si on veut
arrêter cette inflation voilà alors
aujourd'hui moi je suis plutôt pas pour
une nouvelle taxe ça va ça va être
difficile à gérer voilà on va on va
recréer encore un des coûts à côté je
pense qu'il faut plutôt regarder dans ce
qui existe ou alors ou alors en
supprimer me dire voilà on crée une
nouvelle taxe mais on en supprime deux
comme je vous le dis
merci beaucoup merci Merci à VOUS
Jacques d'avoir été avec
du Grand Paris les grands événements
sportifs fermant de développement
territorial c'est à la Une du journal du
Grand Paris merci beaucoup Jacques
paquet d'avoir été avec nous on va
terminer en parlant des sénatoriales
Vincent delay vous êtes à nouveau
candidat oui c'est pas un scoop non on
va
voir les sénateurs sortants en Essonne
il y a deux sénateurs de droite vous
sénateur du centre vous partez sur une
liste autonome vous avez envisagé de
partir ensemble à un moment nous on
était moi j'ai toujours été libre
indépendant j'ai été avec Jocelyne
guidez libre indépendant en 2011 je l'ai
été en 2017 je suis à nouveau en 2023 il
y a de la constance il y a de la
fidélité il y a l'amitié donc moi c'est
des choses qui sont importantes pour moi
y compris en politique donc c'est vrai
qu'au continu sur cette ligne là après
c'est vrai que les rapports de force ont
un peu évolué en Essonne en 2017 c'était
4 pour la droite et le centre et un pour
la gauche aujourd'hui on serait plus sur
trois deux donc c'est vrai ça suffit
municipale il y a eu un certain nombre
de villes qui ont été perdu par la
droite et le centre ça vous inquiète du
coup vous craignez de perdre un siège
on perdra sans doute un siège comme je
vous dis c'est ces trois deux plutôt que
4 ans donc
c'est plutôt bon le centre écoutez moi
j'espère que ça sera pas le centre que
on gardera avec Jo Jocelyne nos mandats
on a beaucoup on a beaucoup travaillé on
a fait pas mal de choses et on est très
complémentaire puisque moi je suis
plutôt sur les finances la gestion et
Jocelyne est plutôt sur le social donc
c'est je pense que c'est très
complémentaire après vous dire qui sera
encore là en octobre prochain je peux
pas encore le vous le dire mais vous
êtes un peu inquiet sur sur le maintien
de vos deux sièges sur les deux sièges
du centre il faut il faut se battre vous
savez une élection si jamais gagner
d'avance donc il faut il faut quand même
travailler il y a beaucoup de
concurrence il y a des gens de qualité
qui ont bien travaillé donc tout ça ça
nécessite que on travaille et c'est ce
que l'on fait actuellement sur le
terrain en contact des élus locaux et
vous pensez que la gauche remportera un
siège du coup
c'est sûr pourquoi je suis quasi sûr
qu'il remporteront un siège après le
débat c'est de savoir s'il y en aura
deux
après les sénatoriales est-ce que pour
vous le groupe centriste auquel vous
appartenez doit réfléchir à son
positionnement est-ce que pour vous vous
devez rester alliés de la majorité de
droite au Sénat donc DLR ou est-ce que
vous devez vous rapprocher de de la
ligne d'Emmanuel Macron et du groupe
macroniste pour se rapprocher il
faudrait qu'il y a des signes déjà des
signes d'ouverture de volonté
aujourd'hui on en ressent pas du tout
donc aujourd'hui on est j'allais dire on
est libre indépendants comme je le suis
moi en Essonne ça me convient
parfaitement on a on a une ligne qui est
la nôtre on est au centre droit et au
centre au centre
droits on en fait partie je pense pas
que ça change après les équipements
dessinatoriales je ne pense pas après il
peut y avoir des discussions rien n'est
jamais figé vous savez en politique on
ne grave pas dans le marbre les choses
peuvent évoluer en tout cas nous on a
envie d'être utile au pays on a envie
d'être utile voilà pour pour redresser à
certains de de secteurs qui comment
est-ce que pour être utile au pays il
faut aller jusqu'à passer un accord avec
le gouvernement selon vous mais
peut-être qu'à un moment donné ça serait
nécessaire je moi je n'ai plus rien je
n'ai plus rien à ce stade mais
aujourd'hui on sort pas de signe
annonciateurs qui vont dans ce sens-là
donc vous attendez un signe d'Emmanuel
Macron et de son gouvernement bah on
attend la majorité déjà ça serait un
élément de réflexion s'il y avait un
signe s'il y a pas de signe je vois pas
pourquoi on va on va passer notre temps
à réfléchir et en discuter alors que on
a plein de choses à faire merci
de rien merci beaucoup
[Musique]
avec nous et bonne campagne sénatorielle
du coup les sénatoriales je le rappelle
ce sera le 24 septembre prochain merci
d'avoir été notre invité dans 20 minutes
dans le club des territoires on
reviendra sur ce qui s'est passé ce
weekend en Russie et ce putschavorter de
Wagner contre Poutine ce dernier sortile
affaibli de ces dernières heures quelles
conséquences sur la guerre en Ukraine ce
sera le débat dans 20 minutes mais
d'abord on va cueillir notre prochaine
invité c'est Stéphane le folk qui nous
rej